千万不要搜尝,马上各位以后不要搜尝我的短视频
没用,搜尝就是火藏草
经济以后,我就没见过出来了
给自己感动物下,其实学的东西没用
我今天和大家分享一下
到底该怎么学习
我在旁边走了很多关路的
包括在学习公众该怎么证钱
刚付到完孩子就标罢了,想到他说啥了,老会据
我以前是不会学习的,走得很多关路,我是中卖什么
后来还去北达汤厅
当时说真的很运门
我是一个特别爱学习的人,而且特别请问的人
希望看出国兰军书
每天晚上都要学很久
但是我发现一个很奇怪的现象就和我一块学习的人
人家学完没多少事,就能赚钱
我是学了半天
就学不会,就学不懂
我是奔嘛还是怎么会说
我就不明白
后来发现这种学习叫长属学习
长属学习
什么叫长属学习呢,就是把那个吃水一点点都会搬
这边输了
买回去
这个客不错
加点加点
那个财量不错
把它拿过来
硬盘上
各种各样的资料
各种数都看
然后也贝也寄到脑子,但是用不出来为什么
因为那个支持是屋里灵的
我们学支持很容易就你领寫还是很容易的
但是你真正做的时候就麻烦了为什么
因为你的学习是真空是学习
就和那个
一颗院校的学生一样
解好的时候,干的什么事是真空的
当你真正实际功的时候
你是要过那个文化的
当年能把它掉入它的过程中
你是要靠两个
应用和实现的
所以我们很多人都倉注的学习
都藏在一类的
其实你有一种感觉,我好像会了
知道过批,就你用不出来
我自己会这样,没有老实知道
就真的就是很常常先,我这位自己是笨
后来发现不是,其实就是学习方法的问题
后来也是偶然那些会我发现一种是一方法
什么学习方法呢,叫Learning in Public
就是在大厅广中下学习
我就从一个
不断倉处的小倉走,把它变成了一个,就是
习近空的空中
到底该怎么做呢
就是我把我的学习过程成仙出来
我把我的学习过程成仙,我答应我看
我就这么做的
其实我们很多老会都是都理解
就是我做,我学了个东西,然后我是怎么理解的
然后我是怎么用的,我是怎么失败的
人们很多人喜欢这个东西
就是
加继不之前
就那个巨墨之前,大家去体会一下
比如说
我们去做个东西,人家很多时候不只买这个餐,还要看你怎么做的
一大利的那个
烧烤割,对吧
并一点儿,对不对,大家都喜欢
来互动的
所以的话就是
你学习一个东西的时候,你遇到的那些卡
然后这个空,这叫闭空之南,对很多人说广路的
然后你学一个东西,怎么一步一步从能到一的
哎,这个叫新手之南
很多人是喜欢的
你看包括我我们自己老会问我说,或者说你能不能,我能不能跟我们演示一下
你是怎么学习的吗
你是怎么用AI的吗,你是怎么打电池哭的吗
你能够演示一下,你到底怎么拍完视频的吗
你是怎么创过的吗
就是人们喜欢看这个东西
那很多人说,我不是说你AI,你就是不是专家太好的
因为说你是专家的话,你的那个那种和人们就贴得比较远的
最好的方法是比人快半步
哎,这个时候你会发现你的东西对他来说,是特别特别有帮助的
但是我们很多人就会有一种心理人爱
哎呦,我怕人家说我,就这吹吹怎么,我叫你个方法
就是你每次把自己的一些想法,一些经验、分享出来以后,半成平啊
就分享出来的时候,或者不愿意,我也在学习这些东西
这是我的体会,我的理解,你们有什么看法和建议呢
这个时候你会发现你的心理炸就出来了,就发现了,我不是冒充的人爱,我就这个学生爱
我只是,我和他一样,我只是把我的经验分享出来
然后你会发现你的心理炸已经没有了
同时有人会跟你反过,这个时候你会发现对你原谅的知识不错
在这个公主,你反而能够更好的去学习
你会通过交顾的和先生生活中的,看到各种角度的学习
同时在这个国人中,你还能获得一些分辞
而且你会发现,你还能转到一些钱
所以,不要等准备好了再去做,想到了以后马上就去做
人民币币克,不要再做那种
不要再搜尝啊,不要再做倉属是学习啦,对吧
这个搜尝价就是活弹场进去以后出不来
那很能说,我的普通人能做,这个就是给普通人做的
各位,怎么上钱呀,普通人这么着急
你所有别的不复通了
你才能转到钱